we're back with even more interesting
facts about tears of the kingdom and
we've got quite the variety today so if
you still enjoy this series you know
what to do just let us know by hitting
that like button let's go
by now most players have found that you
can create handy ice blocks when using
ice on a body of water but what you
might not know is that you can create
ice long blocks as well by using the ice
emitter instead and sliding along the
surface in a line it will make for a
longer ice blocks that can use to create
larger things the same rule applies to
using hydrants on lava as well to make
longer stone slabs than normal and yes
you can use water on lava to make slabs
but also ice works just as well
[Music]
when up against the Lionel most players
think bombs get dough bones stuff for
decent damage or maybe even a puff
shroom to sneakily get some free hits in
but one item might be more useful than
you think muddle buds muddling changes
an enemy's attack pattern to be more
aggressive and up close and for lionels
this means preventing them from pulling
out their bow this is huge because for
players who battle lionels often they
know once the bow comes out you can't
stun the Lionel anymore which can be
quite a headache this can go even
farther by being able to re-stun linels
from behind for some reason allowing
link to Pummel Linus into submission
from behind over and over
foreign
if you look super closely attaching
certain types of materials to Link's
Shield will change the Parry animation
most blunt objects will keep the old
animation but fusing Blades of any kind
to Link's Shield will make him Parry his
shield in a sideways cutting motion
previously we mentioned that Zora are
fond of water well gorons aren't quite
fond of fire but of course aren't really
phased by it either just annoyed
on a similar note if you pour cold water
on gorons during a hot bath they'll tell
you to cut it out because it's too cold
when cooking up a meal most players know
from breath of the wild that Dragon
parts and star fragments guarantee
different special types of critical
cooking a great way to make meals more
powerful but in tears of the Kingdom
they added two secret ingredients that
also guarantee critical cooking golden
apples for critical food meals and give
dough guts for critical elixirs and yes
critical cooking during Blood Moons
still works too
when fighting smaller constructs some of
their attacks can be hard to judge the
timing of parries or flurry rushes if
you're having trouble a key tell is to
look them in the eye as they'll light up
red just as they're about to attack this
can really help you learn their attack
patterns and retaliate accordingly a
couple subtle changes from breath of the
wild to tears of the kingdom is to rock
octa-rock armor which before were
basically completely Invincible to any
physical attack while hiding underground
well this time any crushing attack will
break it open revealing the octarok
underneath
another small change is the ability to
catch boomerangs while mounted on
lionels which in breath of the wild was
impossible
and waterfalls got an upgrade as well as
smaller waterfalls and breath of the
wild before were unclimbable now with
the redesign they're fully usable in
tears of the kingdom and you can even
slightly steer while climbing up
waterfalls too
at some points you may have seen a
waterfall pouring down from the sky
islands each one is guaranteed to touch
down during rainy weather when the extra
water helps it reach down to Hyrule one
combat upgrade from breath of the wild
is with shock arrows everyone knows that
shooting shock arrows at water or metal
conducts electricity but now any wet
surface can be conducted this is just a
bonus and damp caves where wet walls can
be used to your advantage
did you know that aracuda can be flurry
rushed
and on top of that just like he's they
immediately die from being parried
players may have found that smoke is
affected by natural wind pushing it in
different directions but another
interaction is stronger gusts which
actually blow away the smoke entirely
yeah
on a similar subject Elemental like
likes throw a barrages of damaging
Elemental orbs but these just like smoke
can be pushed around by wind any fan or
Gusty attack can dust away fire or ice
version attacks
korok puzzles with missing rocks often
require link to ultra hand or carry the
rock to the puzzle
[Music]
but fuse is a much more efficient
solution just attach the rock then walk
over to the puzzle
[Music]
while it's not very economical a quick
and lazy way to get from point A to B is
to summon a single steering stick and a
rocket the game will automatically place
the stick on the rocket no matter the
order then you can just Ultra hand
attach and mount it to be quickly on
your way
several select material attachments such
as horrible and horns stones and many
more can change weapons to be able to
crush oars or rocks but you'd be
surprised that select zonai Parts can
also have crushing abilities also known
as shatter this includes the hover Stone
stake stabilizer homing cart hydrant
stoves and Rockets but only when shot
from a bow this in certain situations
can actually increase your damage
significantly such as against Talus and
Brocks whose ore-based weak points take
extra damage against crushing attacks
such as this compared to normal strikes
or any other means now we've got a
couple Secrets after completing the wind
Temple coming up so if you haven't beat
that yet spoiler warning ahead when
fighting colguera most players simply
shoot the weak points well once you get
past the spiky exterior barrier not only
can you plunge attack the weak point you
can actually just dive ahead first even
through both layers of ice it's actually
so fragile that it even buckles under
Link's weight just standing on it
here's my hands down favorite detail
about tulip after completing the wind
tumble and saving Guido Village Teba
passes down the original legendary Great
Eagle boat down to his son toolin thing
is this bow unlike your copy is
extremely special besides having
ravali's original scarf attached to the
back of the bow on the grip there are
two feathers one pink one white one
feather from his mother sake and one
feather from his father Teba
also when wearing the VA Meadow Divine
Helm with a vow of tool and activated
the Avatar will wear the ancient Sage's
Helm to match try it out with each Sage
heads up now we're gonna go into big
final boss spoilers
very beginning of the game Zelda is seen
carrying around a torch and drops it
during ganondorf's attack
well at the end game down gloom's Lair
where she dropped it the torch is still
there lying on the ground
in the very final showdown between link
and Ganondorf Ganondorf often does
multiple Gloom based attacks that are
difficult to block and destroys Link's
maximum Hearts throughout the battle
well these can be reflected with the
master sword but not only that the
master sword beam works just as well to
deflect Gloom and if you acquired the
master sword before the battle link will
draw this iconic blade that's been
powered up by Zelda's sacred power while
the thing is with a glitch available
from a previous patch it's actually
possible to bring the original master
sword from before the power-up into the
fight with Ganondorf as well this blade
is the real deal since it also glows
brightly in the presence of evil the
difference is this sword is both
canonically and gameplay-wise inferior
as it can't get the critical damage
boost that Zelda's Master Sword gets
and unlike the powered up Master Sword
which can shrug off Gloom easily this
original blade is unable to reflect
ganondorf's Gloom attacks
this is starting to look all too
familiar
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below and of course for More Tears of
the Kingdom content stay right here on
Gamespot
foreign
[Music]